wait that was a weird laugh
how did that laugh okay let's play e4 on
berserk too
even i know it's a loss i'm in nowhere
you guys hear how it laughed that was a
very weird laugh
okay ponziani time try for a godly
gambit at some point
oh like like gotham
uh maybe but this is a godly ponziani
it's even more godly than any any godly
gambits
okay so this is a this is a line
okay knights are lined up they're gonna
do some weird
tick-tock dance what is this move i
don't think i've ever seen this move
before
it doesn't look like a good move
it's the type of move like i just want
to punish
i mean very tempting to like somehow
smother me
[Music]
i'll start with queen f3
the problem for black there's no knight
f6 here because i take it
there is a five
it's interesting
i'm tempted to just go insane and play
g4
um
it's my first time watching and i
discovered you on flickr haha
oh wait
another person oh
almost almost as tasty as canadian bacon
i appreciate that
i'm not seeing what to do here actually
okay i want to do fun things
maybe something
i gotta watch my time too
[Music]
and just start with like bishop d3
just pressuring the knight
so one thing um for black this pawn is
pinned
to the f7 square so i'm threatening just
to win a piece
i'm also threatening to win a pawn if
lock somehow defends two attackers one
defender
yeah that's a natural move
so i'll play c4 and getting ready to
develop
wait is my light just trapped
my knight's just trapped i have this
move though
c4 was so careless
i'm losing a piece here
oh this is really bad
i wanna so i wanna take and then knight
g4 the problem is b2 then hangs
and c4 is a really really not good move
um i guess i'll have to treat this
as a gambit
gamuting my knight
and my time okay so i'm just down a
piece
man opponent played this like weirdly
but
it worked out well for black
and afterwards i'll have to see
the better way to play i'll play h4 here
i agree about the the early chess i'm
not sure if this is
such great chess or good chess
it's been it's been a rocky start so far
hi eric first time catching your stream
first saw your stuff on my screen
and wanted to see what other platforms
you were on
i can't even remember if i if i had a
myspace
i think maybe i did but then it just got
deleted
i'm not sure that's so long ago
anyway um i'm still down the piece but
there's there is compensation here
a nice open h file a nice little pin
here
and the great thing oh that's a good
move
as i say the great thing is that the h
file is going to open
but maybe i'll keep it closed if i take
like takes takes uh the bishop defends
everything
actually let's play this move i'm
keeping the tension
keeping the pin for a while now keep up
the good work
oh thank you thank you eric powell i
like your name
but you misspelled eric kind of but i'll
forgive you
thanks for subbing for three months
um okay let's take a pawn
okay so i have i have two pawns for a
bishop
but i have a nice attack
i mean a lot of a lot of potential
attackers
g4 ideas
i think i'll start with g4
i'm still debating which move will make
more sense
as it looks so nice to open the h file
and threaten made on each seven but if
the bishop like for example bishop d3
i take and then takes blocks defending
whoa
first of all thanks for subbing to
yotwaki thanks for the 50
i really appreciate that maybe i'll have
to stream
at this time more often
thanks so much
okay that's yet another way to to wake
up
yeah i appreciate like all the love all
the supports
and especially the
the now mating attack i think bishop d3
was a the better way to go
um i could have taken the bishop
but now now it's a made in one threat
and i don't
know how black
defends actually i kind of
i kind of do know there's maybe a couple
defensive moves
but this should be good for white
and thank you this is chuck 99 subbing
for seven months
and what are our chances of seeing you
open a 30
000 30 000 box of pokemon cards
um i'm not sure
wait do i have queen h7
i mean i could just take the bishop
i'll take the bishop
yeah i used to be into pokemon back when
i was in kindergarten
so basically when i was six years old
and then it was kind of a phase
that was very short-lived
but if someone wants to send me a pack
of pokemon cards i would
i would be up for opening them on stream
but for the most part people have been
sending me tea
which i do very much appreciate
oh and hello to death metal donkey kong
first time here from youtube now that
comment i believe
the flickr comments the the myspace
comments
those were a bit more suss
that reminds me i scheduled a youtube
video
for
oh for seven a.m
am i not meeting all the queen defends
but again i'm threatening queen h8 mate
now
i have to be a little bit careful
first time watching from napster oh oh
from knapp's oh
wait didn't napster go
out of business in like the early 2000s
alexa when did napster go out of
business
oh that was a really bad move february
1st 2001
2001 oh
i completely forgot the night could take
i'm down a piece again but i
am i mean i might still be okay
i also have 18 seconds i should probably
stop looking at chat
but thank you skapao subbing with prime
yeah let's focus oh he's gonna have so
many distractions
so i have a youtube video um
this is the next youtube video uh
but let's
okay let's focus first
i'll probably just release a video after
i finish streaming
be nice if i can just raid my own video
so queen g5 most likely and then i think
king d1
because then there's no there's no
checks if the king moved up there
there'd be rook takes f2
good morning from bc oh good morning
mr incredible
okay so um this is a force mate threat
i really have to calculate on my
opponent's time
this is probably also
it should be force mate i'm not sure
though
so real cure king here here
oh there's a funny line okay this is
mating right
i was arguing rook e8
wait this is just me next move okay
i survived it's kind of a messy game
i don't know if i'm proud of that but
it's another
it's a ponziani win really enjoyed your
collaborations over the past few months
lots of good conversation funny moments
and great chess come out of those
hope to see more in the future oh thanks
for that
yeah there will definitely be more um
this month
stay tuned in the process of scheduling
some
i appreciate that nicholas996
okay so a few things to address there
um analysis board oh also i'm going to
change
so i had this scheduled for 7 am
maybe 8 30 i don't know i'll probably
just manually release it but let's be
safe
and click done
and save okay
okay
so first of all i'm wondering if my
opponent
like saw my youtube video because
there's a trap here
which a lot of people fall into actually
the most popular move on the chess
is falling into the trap is g6
and there were some like some
opportunities for black to play this
during the game
but after d6 bishop b5 if people haven't
seen the youtube video
it's one of my most recent ones
a youtube channel link is in the chat
but uh yeah this this is devastating for
black because white's controlling these
two squares
and white's going to win a lot of
material
so g6 was played which engine says is a
mistake
and then queen f3 engine says is dubious
wow so stockfish wants me to play knight
g4 here
which is kind of bizarre
i mean there's some ideas if this nine
moves then they're smothered mate that
would be nice
but bishop g7
so it's going for this idea in one of
castling
oh wow oh that's a cool line
so we play knight g4 to like kind of
secure the square and if we
i mean bishop h6 kind of provokes back
to castle
but then there's a nice tactic to take
take queen d4
and the knight on g4 ensures that we're
winning this knight
and actually of knight f6 we mate
if king actually if king g8 we also mate
so only move is f6 and then we take if
f5 we get forked but then we
we go away with check
okay lesson learned i mean it's g6 is a
very rare move
but it's something that hopefully i
won't forget if i run into this again
uh knight g4 is a really cool idea
and the battle gnome thanks for subbing
and cf gauss see if guys
cf sent me
oh i'm going to flex my tea how about
that
i was sent so much tea by by cf gas look
at all this tea
i sent uh egyptian licorice
but i was sent two not two
not three but
actually i sent maybe five or six boxes
but here's four
oh no ah